Welcome to the 42nd Annual
Dr. Martin Luther King,
Jr. Celebration.
We're excited about
today's event,
and we're happy that you're
here today to celebrate with us.
I would like to take this
moment to thank President Rafael
Reif and
[? Christine ?] Reif who
are our hosts for this morning.
I would also like to
thank our honored guest
and keynote speaker,
Freeman Hrabowski, III,
President of the University
of Maryland, Baltimore County.
Thank you for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]
Last night at a special dinner,
the MLK, Jr. Leadership Award
Winners were announced.
We are very pleased to recognize
these individuals and groups
who embody the ideals
of Dr. King in service
to the community.
Today, I would like to share
with the audience this year's
award winners.
The names of this year's
winners and all the names
I'm about to announce
are in your program
if you want to follow along.
Please stand up as
I call your name.
Please hold your
applause until the end.
Rasheed Auguste.
[CLAP]
[LAUGHS]
La-Tarri Canty.
La-Tarri?
George Chao.
Barbara Johnson.
Ethan Zuckerman.
Fossil Free MIT.
Black Graduate
Student Association.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
Now I would like to recognize
the 2015 to 2016 MLK visiting
professors and scholars.
Please stand as
I call your name.
And again, please hold your
applause until the end.
Baratunde Cola, Lashanda Korley,
Israel Ncube, Hakeem Uluseyi,
Kenneth Reeves.
Jacquelyn Taylor.
[APPLAUSE]
I would like to thank all the
members of the Martin Luther
King, Jr. Celebration
Subcommittee
of the Presidential Committee
on Race and Diversity
to whom we owe this
wonderful event.
Please stand as I
call your names.
Committee members include Raul
[? Bulkee, ?] La-Tarri Canty,
Shannon Clark, Sharon
Clark, [? Philip ?] Clay,
[? Sally ?] [? Hashlangar, ?]
Ebony [? Urn, ?] Alice Johnson,
William [? Kendrum, ?]
[? Deborah ?] [? Lieberman, ?]
Paul [? Paravano, ?] [? Xena ?]
[? Queen, ?] [? Christine ?]
Reif, [? Marina ?]
Robinson, Toby,
[? Winer, ?] Reverend [? John ?]
[? Wesnick. ?] Thank you all
for contributing to the
success of this event.
[APPLAUSE]
The theme for this
year's celebration
is Truth and Power:
Students Leading for Change.
We're here this
morning to celebrate
life and legacy of
Dr. King, but also
to reflect on the question,
what can and should
be done in the face of
systematic injustice.
Individual actions
can make a difference,
but do they add up
to something more?
How can we work together
for broader and deeper
social changes?
Dr. King was able to
mobilize a generation
to challenge [? Reese's ?]
Laws and practices
through civil disobedience
and collective action.
It is our turn now.
What is the next step?